today on the matt welsh show the war in
american history continues and now it's
moved way beyond
simply removing statues of confederate
generals we'll discuss the latest on
that front today also five headlines
including democrats in texas leaving the
state in order to prevent the passage of
bills
they oppose these are the same people
who complain about obstructionism
usually
and will the by administration be fact
checking your text messages a new report
makes that claim also in our daily
cancellation we'll talk about an article
in a scientific journal claiming that
geology is racist and the reason they
give for this claim is so
unbelievably insane and stupid that it
may actually
succeed in shocking you we'll find out
all of that and more today on the matt
walsh show
after a very long build-up the town of
charlottesville virginia finally removed
the statues of confederate generals
robert e lee and stonewall jackson
uh this past weekend and in the midst of
the the mindless
statue toppling craze that has infected
our country for several years
this this event was all but inevitable
according to the southern poverty law
center a group i normally would not cite
as any sort of authority or reference
at all but whose numbers here are
probably basically reliable
a total of 168 confederate quote-unquote
confederate symbols were
torn down and removed in the year 2020
alone including 94 monuments
now virtually all of these statues were
removed following the death of george
floyd nobody's ever offered a coherent
explanation as to why the death of a
violent felon and drug addict
who was resisting arrest should have
precipitated a re-evaluation of anything
let alone
historical monuments i mean what
precisely is the connection
between george floyd's demise and a
statue of a confederate general
that hasn't been made clear it's even
less clear how the mad
rush to eliminate these statues
represents cultural progress
a sign that we had made progress
and had healed the deep wounds from the
civil war was that many americans could
remember and recognize
men who fought on both sides we were
able to view it with a
mature and nuanced perspective in the
light of historical context
the fact that we are less able to do
that today
as we are further away from the event
itself the fact that we can't even bear
to see an image of any man who lived in
and fought for the south would seem to
indicate that we've gone backwards not
forwards
you know it's a mark of maturity and
growth when a married couple
can talk civilly or even laugh laugh
about old arguments they've had or
past offenses that they caused one
another but if they find that suddenly
those old arguments and offenses are
becoming the source of contention yet
again
that's a sign that their relationship
has regressed
not progressed but lee and jackson were
not the only historical figures to be
toppled in charlottesville over the
weekend
on the same day the city council
convened in
an emergency meeting quote unquote with
only 20 minutes notice
and decided to tear down a beautiful
statue of the great explorers lewis and
clark
which had been proudly standing in its
spot on main street in charlottesville
for over a hundred years now the
priceless work of art has been
removed from view with no specific plans
for where it may go or
what might happen to it now what did the
statue do
to deserve this fate what exactly was
offensive about it
this is lewis and clark they're not
confederate generals
why was it taken down well there's the
stated reason
and then there's the actual reason and
where the left is concerned
those two things rarely align the stated
reason
is that the lewis and clark monument
caused offense to native americans
because of how it depicts their indian
guide and translator sacagawea
the sculpture features lewis and clark
standing triumphantly and looking off
into the distance while sacagawea
is crouched behind them looking down it
was decided by activists including a
descendant
of sacagawea who for some reason was
consulted in this matter i'm not sure
why
it's a distant relative uh you know
over 200 years later and
her opinion matters why but it was
decided by all these people that the
positioning
of the figures on the statue is
offensive because sacagawea is in a
subservient
and submissive pose supposedly
not that this matters at all to the
activists but their interpretation of
the statue is simply incorrect
the guy who sculpted it charles keck
first of all he
he he talked about what he was doing and
why he did it that way and you can go
and look at what he said
he was also originally commissioned only
to produce a statue of lewis and clark
he made a special point to include
sacagawea
and obviously not because he wanted to
disrespect her
he explained why he positioned the
figures the way that he did and this is
what he said quote
the guide sacka julia is at their side a
little to the rear so that she shall
so that she shall not compete too much
in the composition with lewis and clark
remember
this was supposed to be a statue of
lewis and clark
he's including this other uh figure he
continues
by making her look down i've tried to
suggest that they were on a high
prominence
and she was more interested in the
immediate surroundings and not aware of
what was in the minds of the explorers
okay so this is not about subservience
or submission or subordinates
this is about focus by the artist's
interpretation
lewis and clark as the leaders of the
expedition were focused on the long view
you know the ultimate goal while saca
julia as the 16 year old guide tracker
and translator
was concentrating on the immediate
surroundings
it's it's very clear that the artist who
made a point again of including
sacagawea even though she was not in the
original plans
for the monument did not intend to
insult her by memorializing her
she's being honored not demeaned and the
irony here is that the activists
supposedly seeking to protect her good
name
are doing so by tearing down a statue
that honors her
and besides even if the piece is
outdated in its depictions
or slightly offensive or whatever and i
don't think it qualifies as any of that
i don't think it's outdated or offensive
or anything but
even if it was are we at the point
where all works of art produced by
people who lacked our modern mindset
must now be removed from our site
have we reached a point where no art can
be timeless
because any that fails to align entirely
with our contemporary view of things
must be destroyed
yeah we have reached that point indeed
this is a war
on our history as a nation and it's not
just happening in charlottesville
though charlottesville has perhaps
become ground zero for some of this and
we haven't even discussed the other
statue that came down
in that city on saturday in all in one
day
not one not two not three but four
beautiful historic sculptures were
yanked down by demolition crews
and we talked by the way we talk about
the the historical significance of these
statues and
why that's why it's a travesty that
they're torn down for that reason
and it is but these are also works of
art
these are priceless works of art that
someone spent
years making and that have stood there
proudly
for decades or centuries in some cases
and we're tearing all this stuff down
like it's nothing
but the fourth statue was a depiction of
revolutionary war general george rogers
clark
labeled on the statue itself and in
history as the conqueror of the
northwest
clark is the older brother of william
clark of lewis and clark
fame so a bad weekend for the clark
family all told
and he has hailed or at least had been
hailed for his victories against the
british in the northwest territory
the statue depicts clark on a horse
confronting or speaking to a group of
indians
why is that offensive well left-wing
activists who are now the authorities on
art interpretation apparently
um have have their stated reasons and
and here's the washington post
explaining
their reasoning quote the removals can
be traced to years of activism
said anthony guy lopez a uva graduate
and crow creek sioux tribal member who
began petitioning the city to take down
the lewis clark and sacagawea statue in
2009.
he called the twin takedowns an exorcism
of state violence against native
americans
if art can be evil these were evil lopez
said
what this says to american indians is
that violence is part of our lives
that we have to not only accept but
glorify it
now of course violence was very much
a part of life for native american
tribes and really for all people
everywhere during that time period uh
which is depicted in the statues and
throughout all of history before that
and for much of the time
after that up until now and it's and for
a lot of people in the world today it's
still violence is still a part of their
lives
but perhaps more importantly here
neither statue
actually depicts violence there is
nothing remotely violent happening in
the lewis and clark statue
and you've got this activist sign this
is violence what
where what where's the violence on this
statue
lewis clark sacagawea they're all on the
same team
standing there looking out violent
and the george clark statue may imply a
larger context of violence he was a
general engaged in battle after all but
there's nothing violent being displayed
or portrayed
by the work of art in question
so what's the real problem i mean that
can't be that that
that can't be the real problem with
these statues what is the real problem
i think this paragraph from an article
about the removals on u of a
u of uva's website captures it nicely
this is what it says there
the clark statue had long been a source
of pain for native americans at uva
and in the community uva history
professor christian macmillan wrote in
july 20
2020 that both the george rogers clark
statue and the statue of lewis clark and
saga julia
were quote instrumental in creating a
creating and perpetuating the myth
of brave white men conquering supposedly
unknown and unclaimed land
oh yes well we wouldn't want statues
that perpetuate the myth
of brave white men wouldn't want that
that really is the problem right never
mind the fact that lewis and clark
were in fact brave white men
you would have to be in order to forge
ahead into a wilderness
that is unknown to you that's what
someone means when they when they talk
about going into an unknown wilderness
means that they don't know it
so there's no sense in you saying well
it's unknown to you but not to people
that might live there
well obviously but i me talking from my
perspective
i don't know this wilderness and so
that's why it requires bravery
for me to go out into it where dangers
of all kinds lay ahead
and where you know that there's a very
good chance you'll die and whether you
survive or not it is certain that you
will suffer
that takes bravery that is more bravery
than has ever been exhibited or will
ever be exhibited
by any of the morons and the cowards and
infantile babies who are tearing these
statues down
every single historical figure that they
have torn down
all of them more important have
contributed more to society
than any of those losers ever will
yeah lewis and clark were brave so was
george rogers clark
guess what so were robert e lee and
stonewall jackson for that matter they
were brave men
yeah i said it charging into battle
takes bravery it does
and you know the former group the
explorers they did in fact claim
or conquer land that was unknown to them
and oftentimes and oftentimes
unclaimed yes sometimes the land was
occupied by indian tribes
not all the time by the way you're
talking about a a smattering
of indian tribes dispersed
over the entire um continent
it's not like every square mile was
claimed or owned by indian tribes
what did they own the whole hemisphere
nobody was supposed to come here
absurd some of the land though was
occupied by indian tribes and as i've
tried to explain many times these tribes
themselves live by the law of conquest
they claim that land
through violent force they were not
innocent turtle doves living lives of
peaceful serenity
this land like the land all over the
globe was up for grabs
for anyone with the will and might to
take it
might make your tummy hurt when you hear
a phrase that way in modern society but
that's the reality
that's how indian tribes operated it's
how everyone operated at that time
and yet it's been decided that white men
are the villains of history
and the villains of the present day and
what that means is that no white man in
history is allowed to be honored or
remembered or celebrated it's not a
coincidence that nearly every single
statue or monument that's been toppled
over the past year or two
has been a depiction of a white man
it's not like there aren't other kinds
of statues out there
is it a coincidence if almost every
single one
just so happens to be a white historical
figure
it's not now that isn't to say that they
won't eventually the the mob
i'm not saying they won't eventually
move on to other targets
once all of the white men of history
have been thrown on the incinerator i
think they will
i've said that i think eventually
they're gonna be tearing down martin
luther king jr
um for his uh his for the shall we say
problematic aspects
of his life and biography and
personality
eventually they'll get to that this is
after all as as i have said a war on
american history
in its entirety and it is the inevitable
result of critical race theory
the result of a narrative of history
that casts all of our historical
triumphs
as moral failures all of our heroes as
bullies and tyrants and all of our
sources of pride
as sources of shame this is where it all
leads
and it's far from over now let's get to
our five headlines
now we check in with our very good
friends over at charity mobile
i've been a charity mobile customer for
a while now and
i'm proud to support it's not very often
that you can say as a customer
of a of a company that you're proud to
support them i think
as conservatives we do a lot of sort of
holding of our nose when we're
when we're shopping or you know
supporting companies
because so many companies are against us
in the culture but charity mobile is not
they're the pro-life phone company five
percent of your monthly plan price goes
to the pro-life pro family charity of
your choice
there's a lot of other perks that come
with this too it's just a great service
all around you get new activations and
eligible accounts get a free cell phone
with free activation and free shipping
and there's no contracts you have to
worry about termination fees or any of
that nonsense
there's also no risk with a 30 day
guarantee and you also get if you need
it live customer service based right
here in the usa
which i really appreciate and free usage
alerts you get free apps to make
everything easier all that kind of stuff
but the main thing is
you're helping to build a culture of
life in america while supporting a
pro-life phone company so call them at
1-877-474-3662 or chat with them
online at charitymobile.com
all right so i've got to show you this
just to start with
i don't know if i'd call this headline
news but my wife
saw this while running errands just here
in town
and you get it so if you're watching if
you're watching the
the video podcast you got to take a look
at this car i don't know what the deal
is with this but it's covered in
like green fur and baby dolls and
stuffed horses
this is maybe among the top five most
terrifying things i've ever seen in my
life
uh and i want to be careful because i
say that the owner of this car
lives somewhere around us so i don't
want to upset whoever that is but um and
in fairness
they may have just accidentally crashed
into a serial killer's basement
and ended up with all that stuff all
over the car i don't know um i really
don't but
the good news at least is that you never
you have a car like that
you never have to worry about uh
not being able to find your car in a
parking lot
that you don't have to worry about
you're not going to do like what i see i
i run
i gotta get used to the fact that i
drive a pickup now and i'm in tennessee
um so anytime i park and go into a store
if i don't in my if i don't like take a
picture of where i'm parked
as soon as i walk out into the parking
lot i'm i'm lost it's it's a it's a
bewildering site because all of the cars
in the parking lot look exactly like
mine
so i'm just walking through with my key
you know seeing which one will set the
alarm off
you don't have to worry about that with
this car that's the one advantage
and that's all i'm going to say about it
for fear of my own life
but i had to show you because come on
my god all right um joe biden
is giving a speech on voting rights
today at
some point and jen pasake
previewed the speech on monday she was
asked in the white house press
conference what she
what the speech is gonna be all about
and um here's what she says about the uh
you know
about the the speech and also the issue
of voting rights today let's listen
well first um well thank you for the
question uh because he's very focused on
this speech tomorrow one that he
himself wanted to deliver he'll lay out
the moral case for why denying the right
to vote is a form of suppression
and a form of silencing and how he will
use he will
redouble his commitment to using every
tool at his disposal
to continue to fight to protect the
fundamental right of americans
to vote against the onslaught of voter
suppression laws
based on a dangerous and discredited
conspiracy theory that culminated in
assault
on our capital he'll call out the
greatest irony of the big lie
is that no election in our history has
met such a high standard
with over 80 judges including those
appointed by his predecessor throwing
out all challenges
he'll also decry efforts to strip the
right to vote as authoritarian and
anti-american
as a and stand up against the notion
that politicians should be allowed to
choose
their voters or to subvert our system by
replacing independent election
authorities with partisan ones
and he will highlight the work of the
administration against this the
necessity of passing the for the people
act and the john lewis voting rights
advancement act
and how we need to work together with
civil rights organizations
to build as broad a turnout and voter
education system to overcome
the worst challenge to our democracy
since the civil war
the worst challenge to our democracy
since the civil war so apparently
the january 6th uh quote-unquote
insurrection has been demoted
it is it is no longer the worst uh the
worst thing that's happened since the
civil war
i thought that it was it's what we've
been told but now it's i know it's these
voting rights laws
or laws that are meant to uh deny people
the right to vote which
look the phrase the term gaslighting is
used
far too often just like the word grifter
is used far too often in
in discourse today but it really does
apply this there's just one long stream
of
gaslighting from from our anytime we
hear from the democrats
about the voting rights issue this this
these laws to deny voting rights
there are no such laws being passed
anywhere
nobody is attempting to do that those
laws do not exist
and as i always remind you i say this as
someone
who would support those kinds of laws if
they did exist i wish they did
every time i hear democrats say there's
this law in this state they want to deny
people the right to vote
i get my hopes up i say really
thank god finally i'm moving to that
state
and then i look into the law and it's
like no okay you just have to just have
a photocopy of your id
that's it
um because in reality
there actually isn't any universal
god-given right to vote um it's not
inherent to our humanity to have this
right to participate
in um in the democratic process
it's not which is why already
we deny lots of people the right to vote
if you're a felon you're denied the
right to vote
if you're under the age of 18 as it
stands right now anyway you're denied
the right to vote
that's a lot of people so we can't claim
that it's a universal right and
you know an inheritance to us as
god-given
it's something that you have to qualify
for and it can be taken away
that's already the system everywhere
or nearly everywhere
um the question is is only
should we have
should we should there be more of an
effort
you know to protect the voting process
by making sure that the people who are
participating in it
are qualified to participate
i say yes and i say that that is protect
if you really
value the right to vote who
who are the people who really value the
right to vote who really cherish it
or really take it seriously we hear so
much about the right to vote is a sacred
it's a sacred right
i personally wouldn't call it sacred but
i think my position
if it is sacred protects that sanctity
more than the people say ah yeah let
anyone do it open up the floodgates just
let anyone vote doesn't matter
they could they could be you know they
whatever they've been in a in a
cheeto and netflix-induced coma for the
last four years
uh shake them awake carry them
carry them in the cradle position over
to the poles and just dump them
in a voting booth and say yeah but you
know hit one of them hit a name random
it doesn't matter
that's how you protect the sanctity of
voting rights that way
i i don't think so i i
am taking a position that almost no one
else takes at least not
at least among elected republic there's
not any
that i'm aware of i've not heard any
elected republican
suggest that we should actually start
actively and purposefully excluding
people from the voting booth
i wish elected republicans would
advocate that but they're not
um in fact and we're going to talk
more about this in a minute but i guess
we'll go ahead and talk about now
as a matter of fact i think what you're
hearing from
from republicans on voting rights is
quite the opposite of that
governor greg abbott he was on fox news
last night
and he was talking about the texas
democrats who have fled the state
um to prevent to prevent
not not only legislation on voting
rights but many other
many other issues as well he was talking
about them and then he gets it then he
gets into the issue of
of of you know voter suppression and who
are the real voter suppressors in this
country
and here's what he says let's listen but
laura i have to point this out
the thesis that they are operating under
is completely false because
what the texas law does doesn't hinder
anybody's ability to vote
in fact interestingly what texas is
seeking to do is to
add additional hours to vote texas has
12 days of early voting and the hours of
which will be expanded
and we will ensure that hours are
expanded on election day also so their
entire thesis
is completely wrong and compare early
voting in texas
with early voting that we have in
delaware texas has 12 days of early
voting
delaware has zero days of early voting
why am i picking on delaware because
that is where
the president himself voted in the last
election
and if anybody wants to talk about voter
suppression they should be talking about
delaware not texas
yeah the dems are the true vote
suppressors
that old thing for republicans but that
that is what we're getting from
republicans
it's true what he just said that uh
republicans are actually
they're trying to expand it they're you
know in texas they're
going to provide more hours to go vote
expanding early voting and all that kind
of thing
that's what you're getting from
republicans
they actually agree with the democrats
on this issue
while the democrats accuse them of not
agreeing and the republicans response as
always is to say no no we do agree we do
agree
i promise
you should be expanding the hours of
voting expanding early voting
i don't want to hear republicans brag
about oh we've got more vote
early voting than delaware does
there should be no early voting at all
you have election day voting day go and
vote on that day
and if we're talking about a
presidential election you've got
four years to plan for it everyone knows
what day it's going to be
we all know there's no surprise when it
comes time for the 2024 presidential
election we all know when that vote is
going to be
and you know where where you have to go
depending on where you live
to cast your vote you're telling me you
can't schedule the time
with this much notice
that's the way it should be but that's
that's we are heading in the opposite
direction
so as always when it comes to voting and
how easy it should be
really republican democrats are
basically on the same side with a slight
with only just slight differences
now speaking of the democrat lawmakers
leaving the state reading now from the
from the daily wire it says texas
democrat lawmakers absconded from the
state on monday in a theatrical fashion
as they subverted democracy by denying
the legislature
a quorum needed to approve bills in
governor greg abbott's special session
agenda
um quote private planes carrying more
than 50 democrats
there they are there on their private
plane left austin for
for dulles international airport
mid-afternoon skipping town just days
before the texas
house of representatives it was expected
to give early approval to sweeping
new voter integrity laws in the special
legislative session according to the
associated press
the numbers meant the house would not
have enough lawmakers in attendance to
conduct business and could not at least
for now vote on the bill
this is the second time that texas
democrats have bolted from the state to
stop measures from becoming law because
they have no path to permanently block
the voting measure
or a list of other contentious
gop-backed proposals up for debate
according to the report so there you see
them there on their private chartered
flight and they tweeted this out
um or at least the reporter tweeted this
out on plane to
to dc texas democratic lawmakers are
leaving state to break quorum to stop
republican voting bill
veteran capital observers say this is
this is unchartered territory
uh for this photo was taken by a
democrat on the plane
as many people have observed you see
them there on the plane
and none of them are wearing masks at
all
the excuse we're given is that this was
a private chartered plane
which raises a whole bunch of questions
in and of itself
where are you getting this private plane
from
where all of these supposed public
servants
where are they getting all their flying
private all the time
how are they doing that where are they
getting this money nobody asks that
or at least anyone asking it is is not
going to get an answer to the question
okay so you're on private and
technically then uh because it's not any
kind of public transportation you don't
have to wear the mask
okay so what you're what these texas
democrats are telling us
is that the only reason we wear masks
on commercial airlines is because we
have to
why do we have to well because we have
to there's no there's no actual
underlying reason if there's any
underlying reason
for the rule saying we have to wear the
mask then they'd be wearing the mask
voluntarily on a private plane
but they're not because they have their
own rules
texas state representative james
talarico tweeted
just landed in memphis on our way to dc
thank you all for your well
well wishes we left behind our families
our livelihoods and our beloved texas
but our sacrifice is nothing compared to
the sacrifices brave americans have made
throughout history to protect the sacred
right to vote
you're correct that your sacrifice is
nothing i agree with you on that part
because there's no sacrifice at all
you're going on a on a apparently paid
vacation
leaving work can i do that
i wonder how that would fly with the
bosses here at the
the daily wire no notice don't take any
vacation time i just get on a plane and
fly
and then and then i say hey hey don't
worry guys my sacrifice
someone i get a call what are you doing
matt you got to do the show hey listen
my sacrifice i know this is a sacrifice
but don't
don't thank me for my sacrifice
there are other pictures of them on
their bus because they took a bus
and then they took a plane and they took
another bus and they're taking selfie
videos the whole time and bragging about
and talking about their great sacrifice
in one of the uh the photos you can
clearly see
uh there's like an 18 or 30 pack of
miller lite there so
they're going on a little booze cruise
what a great sacrifice
and of course these tasteless hacks
bring miller light of all things
with them so hypocrisy is abound um you
know they're not wearing masks
they're obstructing democracy while cl
while accusing everyone else of being
obstructionist
um they are
the carbon footprint are they worried
about that
all of this fossil fuel they're burning
a lot of hypocrisy a lot of double
standards
but as always the double standard and
hypocrisy is part of the point
because that's the power that they have
that's the message that they're sending
and in a certain way you know it's it's
even though
there's so much hypocrisy and this is a
double standard
and this is nothing but a
self-congratulatory ridiculous
stunt
and i despise democrats with
my whole soul even in spite of that it's
hard for me to get very angry at them
about this
because this is the kind of thing i wish
republicans would do
i mean this is hardball this this is
democrats saying you know what we're not
going to go along with you
at all even when we legally have to
even like even when it seems we have no
power here at all
we still we're not going to give you a
damn inch
we're not we're going to give you
nothing
that part of it i kind of respect i
gotta be honest with you and i wish
republicans would have the same attitude
now granted it's easier to do that when
you have the media on your side because
we know if it was republicans doing this
all the headlines would be republican
fugitives obstructing democracy
there'd be 57 headlines just about the
fact that they're not wearing masks on
the plane
so we know that it is it's a lot easier
when you've got the media on your side
but even so
i can't hate them too much for playing
hardball i can't
because that's what i want republicans
to do
all right next i can certainly hate this
staying with the bind administration
here's something that seems to have
somehow flown
under the radar and this is from
politico i'm going to read this to you
and you tell me if anything jumps out at
you
there's anything here that raises a red
flag i don't know
um it says
the bi-administration is casting
conservative opponents of his cove of
its kova 19 vaccine campaign
as dangerous and extreme adopting a more
aggressive political posture in an
attempt to maneuver through the public
health conundrum well this is nothing
new it's not like this is a new strategy
in a new strategy
liberals are casting their opponents as
dangerous extremists
it's an interesting new strategy we'll
put we'll see if it pays off
but it continues the white house has
decided to hit back harder on
misinformation quote-unquote
misinformation and scare tactics after
republican lawmakers and conservative
activists
pledged to fight the administration's
stated plans to go door-to-door to
increase vaccination rates
the pushback will include directly
calling out social media platforms
and conservative news shows that promote
such tactics
listen to this part biden allied groups
including
the democratic national committee are
also planning to engage
fact-checkers more aggressively and work
with sms
carriers to dispel misinformation about
vaccines
that is sent over social media and text
messages
the goal is to ensure that people who
have uh who may have difficulty getting
a vaccination because of issues like
transportation
see those barriers lessened or removed
entirely
now i don't know call me crazy
but it seems as though they're saying
that the dnc is going to be colluding
with fact checkers to monitor our
private text messages
all in an effort to uh head off
misinformation you know it's for our own
good that's all
you got to understand that if the dnc is
checking in on your text messages maybe
your emails whatever
it's all for your own good if the nsa is
doing it it's all for your own good
because there might be dangerous
extremists out there who are trying to
uh you know talk to you
and and convince you of things
and you're too stupid of course just
like i we're all too stupid
to be able to practice discernment and
that's why we need
big brother who can swoop in and uh
and save the day
now how is so i i saw this report in
politico
and then i was googling to see if
there's been other headlines about this
and there hasn't been anything
how is this not a big deal at least
that's the report that they're going to
be monitoring our private text messages
i guess you know if you have a problem
with it just start your own cell phone
carrier that's all
start your own verizon you don't like it
private company start your own verizon
that i'm sure will be um the response
all right moving on i think it's time
for it's a bit a little heavy today and
maybe it's time for another musical
break
a time to appreciate the uh some some
true art
talk about art too true musical art
so here is uh i don't think it requires
any more setup here it is from
from our friends at tik it's vaccination
day
it's vaccination day
it's time for vaccine shot number two
i've got my mask with pikachu
but i am running seven minutes late
i hope they'll jab me anyway i really
want this shot today
now my fear of covet can abate
i'll see actual real-life people it'll
be
totally strange wow am i so ready for
this
change and for the first time
in forever i'll emerge from my lockdown
for the first time in forever
i'll go catch pokemon downtown
my right wing friends keeps going crazy
all right let's stop with her
i thought uh you had to see that you had
to hear it because i did
no i do not mean to stereotype i am not
one you know i would never do that i'm
against
stereotyping but if this guy does not
live with his mom
uh i i will be shocked
that's all i'll say about that let's
move on to reading the youtube comments
this is from phyllis says not in a
million years could anyone convince me
that jenner is a conservative or is a
republican
or is a woman for that matter well said
phyllis
and needless to say i agree angie says
camilla is so out of touch it's pathetic
or really she's just a liar and a bad
one with that i live in a rural town
that only has one k-12 school for three
towns and i only have to drive about six
miles to a place that'll make copies but
even better
i can just walk into another room in my
house where we have a scanner printer
and a computer
shocking i know you had a scanner
printer and a computer
in your house in rural america
um if someone can't figure out how to
make a copy of their id i'm not sure i
want them voting anyway she
she finishes yeah well that's that's
that's one of the the great reasons for
the voter id
laws i think because i would love to
have the voting test
where we just test your basic knowledge
on civics on american history and that
sort of thing
can you make it like a fifth grade level
i would love to have that but if we
can't have that
then this stuff functions as kind of a
test in and of itself
a basic competency test can you at least
figure out how to make a photocopy of
your id
and send it in can you follow those
instructions if you can't
then that's that you're definitely
someone we don't need even if you're
you know not trying to commit voter
fraud
if you're so in insanely incompetent and
stupid
and you can't figure that out then i
don't think i agree with you i don't
think we need you
in the voting booth um another comment
says i don't think we should be using
the phrase identifies as because it
implies that this is a thing someone can
do legitimately
i would use the terms say they are or
perhaps even pretends to be
this is more direct and to the point if
we're trying to maintain truth
legitimacy of language
and a baseline reality i i get your
point i think identifies as
still it's it's a it's a could be an
accurate description
this is someone who is identifying
themselves you can identify yourself as
anything i can identify myself as an
elephant if i want
it's just it's a it's a claim that i am
making about myself
and it may even be a feeling that i have
a deluded feeling i have about myself
so when i say that this is a man who
identifies as a woman i'm not
agreeing with the claim i'm just saying
that is the claim they're making
um let's see
jared says matt now we demand first rule
of sweet baby gang is you do not talk
about sweet baby gang merchandise you
brought this
upon yourself well speaking of sweet
baby gang merchandise
and uh there we could go many different
places with sweet baby game merchandise
but we
can start with the t-shirt that i've
that i've showed you and there is now i
didn't do this
but someone put together you can see it
here i think this is a change.org
petition
someone made a petition calling on the
daily wire to put the sweet baby gang
merchandise on sale
and uh it looks like they wanted what do
they want 200
they wanted 100 signatures and they
already have 89.
so the people have spoken
i don't know if this is going to result
on the merchandise the merchandise
actually going on sale i can't i can't
promise that
i think petitions generally have no
result whatsoever
because they carry no legal weight
but i just want you to know i'm on your
side on this thing okay
if it were up to me you'd be able to buy
this today
at a very high premium but it's not up
to me and nothing is up to me
but there it is if you want to sign if
you want to cry out
let your voice be heard the democratic
way
then go find that petition and sign it
one thing i hear from people all the
time
when i meet people in public is uh they
say to me
matt you are a fashion god
and uh i really want to hear you talk
more about fashion and your own
sense of style um nobody ever says that
to me at all
uh and that's probably good because i
don't know a lot about fashion but i'll
tell you who does mac welding mac
welding is uh
you know they're so much more than just
underwear that's how they kind of
started
but now they've got a full collection
including t-shirts polos button-ups
shorts pants uh swimsuits and so much
more with light and breathable fabric
technology mac welding keeps you cool
and comfortable
all summer which is really good because
i've discovered in tennessee in the
south is actually
really hot it turns out i didn't know
that so i've been using a lot of
mac welding especially their t-shirts
which are really comfortable
the great thing about mack weldon is
that you don't have to decide between
being comfortable or looking stylish you
can actually accomplish
both and with little effort which is
very good for me
so you gotta try macweld and for 20 off
your first order visit macweldon.com
and enter promo code walsh that's
macweldon.com
walsh promo code walsh for 20 off mack
weldon
reinventing men's basics you know if
there was a
superlative for most likely to be
trending on twitter
it would be i think it'd be me you know
honestly uh no it wouldn't be me
it actually says in the copy that it
wouldn't be me i'm i'm not the guy uh
candace owens
she's the one who'd be most likely to
try i think i tried on twitter a fair
amount maybe not as much as candace but
and this is where i find my worth as a
person isn't how often i trend on
twitter so it's really a competition
anyway
candace owens is who we're talking about
here not myself she has a new episode of
her show candace dropping tonight
tuesday the 13th at 9pm eastern 8pm
central in tonight's episode
she discusses the protests in cuba and
weighs in on marxism with mma fighter
beneal derish so watch candice live
tonight at 9 pm eastern 8 pm central
only on
dailywire.com candace now let's get to
our daily cancellation
[Music]
today for our daily cancellation we turn
to something that somehow manages to be
so ludicrous that i had to spend about
30 minutes googling it just to make sure
that it wasn't some kind of joke or
parody
it is as it turns out no joke at least
not intentionally
the washington free beacon reports on
the news and i'll give you some of the
background before we get to the really
good stuff
reading from the free beacon report it
says top geologists condemned systemic
white supremacy in the field of
geoscience
which concerns the study of earth and
rocks in a manifesto published at the
scientific journal nature communications
the manifesto which was spearheaded by
fort hayes state university geology
professor
hendra ali and signed by 20 academics
asserts that the lack of black
geologists demonstrates the bigoted
roots of the science
they called on colleagues to quash the
racist quote expectations around manners
clothing hair professional attire
language and diction
in an effort to boost diversity in the
field racism has led to the geosciences
becoming one of the least diverse among
all science and engineering fields
racism thrives in geoscience geoscience
organizes
organizations function alongside the
same racist ideologies and practices
shaping society so they're addressing
the lack of
black people in the field of geology
this is no doubt a problem that has
plagued your mind and
haunted your dreams i know that it has
for me i often wake up in a cold sweat
tossing and turning my eyes wet with
tears
my wife will turn to me and say well
what's wrong what's what is it
and i'll say there's not enough there's
not enough and she'll say not enough
what
black geologists we need more diversity
in the geological sciences
this happens like three times a week
i'm seeing a therapist about it now it's
good that the people
who publish this paper are finally
dealing with this problem but as i said
this is only the background we haven't
gotten to the real headline here and
before we do a little more from this
from this paper speaking in general
terms about the need for more
anti-racism education among those who
study rocks it says quote
in considering anti-racism in the
geosciences we cannot ignore the
intersex
intersecting identities of marginalized
people
we must acknowledge the added burden of
inequalities and oppression experienced
by people
and communities with these
intersectional identities such as black
women who are subjected to both sexism
and racism
or when class status disability gender
expression or sexual identity
intersects with other minoritized
identities
indeed focusing on only one axis of
diversity has led to some gains only in
more white women working as
geoscientists
but has not increased the participation
of bipoc
and other marginalized peoples okay
so this is your standard issue racial
grievance mongering so far
the grievance mongers have identified
identified a certain very specific area
of society
in this case the field of geology and
decided arbitrarily that there should be
more black people involved in it
and then they decided just as
arbitrarily that the lack of black
people
is due to racism it couldn't just be
that not as many black people feel like
studying rocks for a living
can't say i blame them no no it has to
be racism that's what it is
this is all as i said pretty standard
fair and then we get to this
listen very closely and this again is
real
access implies that individuals can
obtain the resources they need to safely
pursue their scientific endeavors
regardless of location instrumentation
site accessibility and their identity
historically access has been limited to
mostly able-bodied white cisgender
heterosexual men
as the geosciences strive to be more
accessible the community must recognize
that bipolar and other marginalized
geoscientists
are not marginalized geoscientists
um anyway other marginalized
geoscientists are not
are not always safe in geoscience spaces
for example holding objects
for example a rock hammer has been
viewed as suspicious
and continues to be used as a reason to
call the black to call the police on
black people
which can lead to the death of black
individuals entirely because of racial
profiling
and an unjustified fear of black people
okay
you heard that right geology is racist
because black people are afraid of
holding hammers
this makes me among other things feel
bad for the black cashier who rang up my
items at home depot last week
i mean imagine the psychological trauma
he must suffer on a daily basis
and why are black people afraid of
hammers well because if they hold one
somebody might call the cops and then
the cops will come and shoot them
in fact this is a problem we're told
with all physical objects in general
according to the paper
any activity that requires holding an
object of any kind
can be construed as racist because of
how it endangers black lives
you might not have known this but if
you've ever worked at say the concession
stand at a movie theater
and you handed a black customer his
large bucket of popcorn
after he paid for it you just put his
life in jeopardy
somebody should have come and smacked
that popcorn out of your hands and said
no
don't do that you're going to kill this
man
what are you doing that's an object he
can't hold an object
i mean you should know better honestly
than to go around giving objects to
people of color
it is your unique privilege as a white
person to hold objects
other races of people don't have that
ability they just don't
now um you may ask
many questions um such as has there ever
been a case
has there ever been a case ever in
history even once
of a black geologist being shot by the
cops
for using a hammer to break open some
rocks
the paper would seem to indicate that
this is an epidemic i know it's not an
epidemic i'm just wondering
has it ever happened at all at any point
since the inception of of the field of
geology
has any geologist of any color or race
been killed by the police in the course
of their duty for using a hammer
and by the way if geology excludes black
people because of how it requires the
use of hammers
what about the construction field if
people of color avoid geology because
they don't want to
they don't want to risk their lives by
holding objects what are they doing in
construction
i mean in that field white people are
underrepresented almost 20
of construction workers are hispanic and
12 percent are black which is
proportional with the general population
if if anyone was going to be shot for
using a hammer on the job you'd think
it'd be
a construction workers who oftentimes
are working in cities and populated
areas
not geologists out chipping away at some
limestone in the desert somewhere
but here i am replying a rational
thought to what is wholly irrational
the leftist religion dictates that
everything everywhere must be racist
and it's up to them to you know fill in
the blanks and explain the hows and whys
and in fairness to them it's not easy to
find racism in geology of all things
and this is basically the best they
could do it was an admirable attempt
we must say but still insane
and for that they are of course today
cancelled
and we'll leave it there thanks for
watching thanks for listening
godspeed
[Music]
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadosky
the show is edited by sasha tulmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by nikka geneva and
our production coordinator is mckenna
waters
the matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire
20 21. cubans take to the streets to
protest communism
hunter biden sells his doodles for half
a million bucks
and a genius of the public health
establishment
promises to make life very hard for the
unvaccinated check it out on the michael
knowles show